you fight well douchebag but to truly
succeed in combat you must learn to
harness the power of your farts farting
on an opponent in precisely the right
time is key battle I shall show you how
it's done but first you must take the
gentleman's hook you must promise to
never ever fart on anyone spout
okay farting on an opponent is necessary
but farting on someone's bowels is not
true do you understand all right
then let's begin your training to
conjure dragon shell you must first
clear your mind and take in a deep
breath through your butthole like so
suck it in let it rembo dragon jump now
you ready
dragon shout find the frequency hook oh
my god that was incredible the man could
live 100 years and never again witness a
spell so boisterous could it be that the
prophecies are true could it be that the
dragon bone has come at last in our hour
of need
now let us try your skill on a real
opponent hey hey princess Kenny
could you come here a sec yep okay did
you real quick princess Kenny sir juice
bag wants to show you something all
right you two spark
Suroosh back show faces Kenny the
magical powers I thought you
[ __ ] hilarious dick I was sucking on
em oh okay good Josh your juice bag oh
sweet
Thanks pretty skinny that's all for now
cool cool off home okay but dude
seriously remember don't ever do that on
someone's balls okay seriously you have
master dragon chefs from now on it will
be easier for you I'm going to teach you
how to use a ranged magic attack it's
not easy but being able to come a spell
from a distance can save you in battle
allow me to demonstrate yeah you see how
it works now you tried way back from
where you're standing cut the magic
thrown at your opponent yes yes but now
let us see how you fare against a real
opponent Hey
hey maggot did now Ethan could you come
help is redundant don't touch the check
is complete
yes ah hey sky could you um spar with
use mango Ming he's gonna try to any
move I'm guy now just that coming pal
now it's sweet you knew that [ __ ] right
Scott fais all right Scott go back to
your post - did you use it wisely in
battle douche bag and never dance pose I
saw you on the ship you have pretty good
control over your farts meet me in the
bathroom it's time for you to learn some
real power I can tell you have potential
but you are undisciplined let me show
you what I mean come at me try and fart
on me come on
hi ja see that your farts over there
somewhere
didn't come close so what do you do when
people can block your farts you must
learn to control your farts to move and
release at a specific time and place I'm
going to teach you a fart called the
sneaky squeaker it will become your
greatest ally don't believe me try and
block my attack pay special attention to
the viscosity make your fart detonate
behind me
no you're not forming it right
imagine you're chewing bubblegum with
your butthole
the Liga's Oh mr Mackey now it's your
turn
you sneaky squeaker to distract mr
Mackey over the corner there hey do you
guys hear that sounded like a chipmunk
Keigo very very good now use what I
taught you to sneak inside that Taco
Bell find out what they're up to and
report back here and no matter what
happens never fart on anyone's balls you
got that all right now go
who are you
perhaps here's the American everyone is
talking aboot tanks nah can't be he
can't be a massive spell Cup he doesn't
even know magic he probably doesn't even
know how to fart
he knows dragons shocked any Magician's
apprentice can drag and shout it's not
like he farted into his hand and hit you
in the face with it Philip he can cut us
up if he's really good how come he can't
sneak a fart behind your fat
the sneaky squeaker very impressive he
is worthy of our training after all yes
prepare thyself child it is time for you
to learn some true
your magic is impressive young American
not since Eric von thunderpants of Nova
Scotia have we seen such prowess but now
you must learn to control your anus
muscles in just the right way to change
it spells frequency Oh ye some objects
seem too large to be damaged by magic
but now I will break through it with
Nagasaki oh here watch again
believe in yourselves
that's it now let us see how Nagasaki
works in battle these three pedophiles
from Alberta will have their way with
you unless you damage them all with one
move sake
you have to power you'd get it now go
out and use your in is for the good of
mankind and don't ever ever fart on a
man's balls
you